hello there reject nation Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we have been sent a video
that would the title of it it's got a
yellow dollar bill sign hole good top
ten most I think violent comedy movies
this is from watchmojo.com requested
from youtuber Andrew Hayes that's how
you spell his name it's right here right
now let's watch this these films busted
a lot of guts welcome to watchmojo.com
and today we'll be counting down our
picks for the top 10 most violent comedy
movies before we begin we publish new
videos every day so be sure to subscribe
to more great content for this list
we'll be looking at the comedy films
with the most violent town holders there
are a lot of films out there that take
violence to hilarious extremes but for
this list we're really focusing on films
that are comedies or action comedies -
horror comedies etc and ranking them
based on how well they mesh comedy and
violence I think I'm just gonna head
back to your place show not really like
number 10 Team America or police
weapons aren't usually what spring to
mind when you think of violence but this
satirical action comedy features plenty
of it following the titular hyper
violent fictional American police force
Team America world police parodies the
country's militaristic policing of the
world as well as those who oppose it and
incredibly over-the-top fashion while
also paying tribute to classic puppetry
seen in shows like Thunderbirds the
action features explosions and graphic
bloody deaths that are nevertheless
extremely silly which helps contribute
to the overall tongue-in-cheek tone of
the film Gary
number nine snatch bananas shrimp that's
pretty violent criminal centric Kobe's
set in London snatch follows an ensemble
cast of gangsters and crooks in several
interconnected plots primarily focused
on a diamond that changes hands numerous
times join monster and his promoters the
film contains numerous acts of violence
including beatings and murders with some
of them verging into the territory of
downright absurd unitedly 16 Pink's to
finish the jumpy one sitting
so be wary of any man who keeps a pig
phone like for example one man's bizarre
detailed description of how Pacey
corpses or the Russian who just won't
die sorry
respect staining a Russian will sweeten
the cooties and inspect Estonia but oh
no snacks because I hope there is the
pilot ride to the London underworld they
will have both you and its characters in
stitches
number eight Evil Dead - eight
or you know that to seize its
protagonist smash Williams continuous
battle with the anonymous people that
cleanse him while it acts is something
of a remake to the original the film
exceeds it by upping both the comedy and
the violence with gallons of gore and
some truly hysterical scenes such as
Ash's breakdown which features puppets
and him cutting his own hand
even though two won't be the last for a
party on our list but it's easily the
grooviest number seven Seven Psychopaths
should let that go a spree violent don't
believe some conversions on our list
Seven Psychopaths follows a brighter
trying to finish a screenplay of the
same name
however when he attempts to draw
inspiration from real-life Psychopaths
he soon finds himself in the middle of a
disturbing and violent albeit darkly
funny series of events and then I don't
know if you do know what the Shih Tzu is
or if you don't know what the Shih Tzu
is either way have some pride despite
the couple of murders
she got intense standoff the Ruby is
still come and he uses finances Laurie
learners men and wages personalities of
its characters and their offbeat
dialogue
the meta aspect of the film is fantastic
too as the film operates in a way that
is very self aware of oh media put your
hands up know what I said no never said
crank what it's the bus from speed was a
guy forcing it to seek out exhilarating
and dangerous situations while he
searches for a cure the constant barrage
found landish antics Chelios puts
himself through to keep himself a lot
Frank to is much worse
while his simultaneous quest for revenge
on the people who did it to him is
brutal and often just as funny crank
offers thrills and laughs alike and both
will have your heart beating faster
number 5 Deadpool after Wade Wilson is
tortured disfigured and given abilities
that cure his cancer he sets out to find
the man responsible in a snarky rampage
of revenge as the volatile wisecracking
antihero Deadpool Wade's powers allow
him to quickly regenerate from nearly
any injury and he deals out and receives
plenty in the film's blood splattered
over-the-top action scenes along with
the gruesomely giggle worthy violence
deadpool openly mocks the trappings of
superhero movies through its titular
protagonists signature meta humor did I
leave the stove on this superhero film
earned its R rating with buckets of
blood but it also more that delivered on
the last a combination that had cinema
goers begging for more definitely use
more 11 12 or bust
number 4 this is
here we have another movie that who
loves to play the fourth wall this is
the end follows a group of celebrities
playing caricatures of themselves as
they attempt to deal with an apocalyptic
disaster erupting around them it's egos
versus the end of the world although
many of the team behind the film had
already made a foray into intense
action-oriented comedy with pineapple
Express this is the end of the ante with
a Reuters Hollywood and celebrity
mockery as well as violence that's way
more graphic and way more absurd number
3 Shaun of the Dead when a slacker in
strength renders more friends and loved
ones sick during a zombie apocalypse
the results are simultaneously
half-assed gory and awesome
like many good zombie movies there's a
ton of blood and guts but shown at the
depth of moths and based tributes the
tropes of the genre while providing a
heaping dose as creators signature
humour and an epic albeit mildly toxic
romance all told it makes for a film
that's truly a slice of fry gold how's
that for a slice of front gold number 2
Zombieland speaking of zone comes zombie
land is a post on be apocalyptic comedy
that sees a group of strangers meet on
the road and subsequently share
misadventures while battling the Living
Dead on their journey across America
think of it as undead Bertram but we far
fewer Twinkies than most roadtrippers
would like you know this Twinkie the
film utilizes its study and Sambi
conventions for some gloriously gory
comedic moments like the zombie plants
part to come amazing so then we can't
get some Maria
despite all the steps zone Elena also
has a surprising heart which added to
all the violence and last makes for a
truly memorable viewing experience
before we get to our top pick here hey
[Music]
some pretty disturbing islands in this
guy's head gets crushed all the violent
is like horror movie or at least in this
case action movies
what buzz features an even better
bromance than its predecessor while also
including a more memorable supporting
cast and kicking the violence up to
because accidents there's nobody to
blame do you agree with our pics check
out these other great clips from
WatchMojo and subscribe for new videos
every day
once again WatchMojo has confused me on
how they do their rankings and is they
defined the category in itself well
that's my point and my first question is
is this ranked off of best mood like did
they get a collection of 10 movies and
then they rank them by which ones are
the best just overall films or do they
rank this off of which one of these
comedies is the most violent one then
they went through the list there there's
an evil that two popped up like pretty
early on this list I feel like they're
two more extreme ones it's like very
gory yeah my second question is are some
of these actually considered comedies I
can get on board if it's like primarily
a comedy or it's tied to be a comedy
like Deadpool is an action comedy easily
this is the end this is the end of
sci-fi horror comic death that's like to
me that's a comedy first get a sense Hot
Fuzz action comedy comedy first action
you know spoof whatever the hell we call
it but like crank crank you feel like an
action movie that happens to have a
humorous ability
or Seven Psychopaths I know it falls
under the dark comedy category that
director always feel the darkness wait
how are you comedy are these that's what
I would reach for they're funny in a way
I wouldn't describe as just comedy yeah
it's like snatch while a hilarious film
I feel like it's primarily a gangster
film first honestly it's not that
violent most of the violence that occurs
in the movie is off camera that was one
thing I was kind of concerned about when
I was gonna first watch when I was
younger though like 10 when it came out
was how Gordy's is gonna be and then
most of like the brutal violence is all
happening off camera or you might cut to
a dead body but you don't see a lot of
what goes on in here so I was kind of
surprised like I think in the end it's
tone and it's feeling and vibe it feels
more grisly than it actually is there
are a lot of movies like that generally
- especially I mean when you get into
crime and horror I think because context
can make yeah seems so much more
gruesome than they actually are Team
America World Police I and I could have
kind of knock it off only because of the
fact that it's puppets yeah you get away
with a lot of violins and it's just
automatically funny and it's not really
like yeah I don't know see that's that's
another one where I feel like it earns
its place on the list arguably better
than a crank does for me because I'm
like well the point of this is that it's
funny and they are lampooning
over-the-top violence yeah but yeah
there's something about that where it
doesn't feel quite like the violence is
authentic or real or or there's like a
key crucial element of crunch it just
isn't present and team America's
violence because of how silly it's all
meant to be because yeah you're
undercutting the violence with the
puppet whereas I feel like movies like
this is the end those are movies that it
can be shockingly violent and the
violence then becomes an element of the
comedy because of how much contrast yeah
what the characters are doing and
because similar to pineapple Express
which both have moments where they're
shocking violence there's that after
effective it's so funny because of how
violent it is but it's also has certain
scenes where the violence is not meant
to be funny and it's like they would
balance it out where you have like okay
that clip in pineville Express Gary Cole
shoots a guy in and by the window and
it's not a funny death scene it's funny
of how Stefano gets like smoky and like
freaking out watching it but the death
itself isn't funny with him there's a
later shower Danny McBride shoots the
guy's foot that's funny
you know like it's so gory and such a
ridiculous thing to shoot off but it's
really funny see these lists make me
wonder if the team over at WatchMojo
sometimes like gets a prompt and is just
left to kind of fill it in with new
however best they can I mean these are
all good movies you know I mean I think
they're all like great movies I can't
really think of what else to add on to
this list I feel like something like
shoot-'em-up would almost work better
than crank because shoot him up is kind
of lampooning sure harder than crank is
like if I just sometimes don't
understand what the list is but these
are all good movies and they are all
like funny violent films and all Island
it's like a figure of a crank I heard
you could put like drag me to hell or
army of Darkness or something you put
like any of those films on here - yeah
totally they totally could have gotten
horrible mentions but then I guess my
next question is what this come as game
out 2019 you could have put drag me to
hell on here I think Deadpool 2 is more
violent than Deadpool 1 yeah I honestly
think Tucker & Dale vs. evil should have
been on this list I just don't think
it's popular enough it's a cult film
know well enough know yeah and I think
that's the reason why it's not on this
list but if anyone has seen Tucker and
Dale vs. evil there are deaths in that
movie that are flat-out hysterical like
that was a random film I put on one day
I really seen the image and I've heard a
couple people say it was funny knew
nothing about it it's violent as a super
violent but it's also hysterical so
everyone thought about violent comedies
you could have easily knocked off a
couple of these or one of these for
Tucker and Dale eyes I don't agree with
the honorable mention section boy I'm
not dissing WatchMojo they asked do you
agree with our list this is
participating in the question right now
yeah this is a list for me I'm like put
some of those honorable mentions in the
main list
remix the main list yes you know put
some stuff behind some other stuff well
either way I'm glad they put this video
together he's always been
for fun topics alright guys well what
violent comedies you wish were mentioned
on here
do you agree watch my shows list comment
below you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click our notification
bell to you can go ahead and check us
out on pet 3 on hey before we wrap this
up I want to get a patron today shout
out to a man named Andrew Hayes listen I
got that face app thing paid premium for
it $400 just so I could flash this image
on screen
I had Andrew as an old guy you're a GILF
man it's gonna be my next month of
shoutouts
everyone's hold and then a month after
that make them like younger or do like
hippie versions this could be the shout
out machine that keeps on giving
how many of them were Mel Gibson faces
yeah how accurate is this soft 25